what song do you remember last crying to
oh gosh well
i mean as you know i i i
literally dedicated
my book to leonard cohen he's played
such a huge role in my life like i love
him i love him
um
and i've loved him with this crazy love
that i've never been able to understand
for decades
i think i understand it a little better
now but
so you guys so you're better friends
with him than me i'm jealous
so
um
does it make you is it the musician or
the human too because the human is a
it's a tortured soul in a way
i'd say it's the musician
it's the musician and i actually was
thinking about this the other day i mean
obviously he's not
alive anymore but
i was kind of running the thought
experiment you know if he were
alive still and i had the chance to meet
him in person
would i want to do that
and i'm not really sure that i would
because
he
represents for me symbolically
everything
well everything i'll
end the sentence right there
and so and and i think that's okay you
know i think people can
can express something through their art
that they might or might not express if
you were just like hanging out with him
and having a coffee
and i'm happy to know him that way
he can express himself i'm sure in the
way that you know him as over coffee too
it just requires
um
like a focus
of remembering of like a deep focus of
connection that's why i like when i
interact with folks
um
it's so draining for me because i'm
putting all my whatever weapons i got in
terms of like deeply
trying to understand the person in front
of me
and doing that dance of human
interaction the the humor
the intense kind of
delving into who they are
um so it which requires like
navigating around like small talk type
of stuff and
and just like compliments and so on in
general like people depending on the
culture depending on the place they'll
sometimes flower stuff with smiling and
like compliments like oh yeah i love you
this is great
i guess that's all great but you want to
get to the core of like
what are the demons in the closet let's
talk about it you know and that could be
exhausting that can be really exhausting
so from a leonard co perspective you get
more and more famous it can be hard
sometimes
because he probably is also an introvert
oh yeah i know he was an introvert
because he actually tweeted about my
book when it came out um so that was a
precious moment for me something about
we should all be listening to the quiet
i can't remember exactly what he said
um
but yeah yeah no he definitely was
he struggled with with uh depression
which i wonder if that's something
that's also connected to introversion
um well perhaps not actually perhaps
that they're very disjoint and and also
it's connected to sensitivity and many
sensitive people are introverts so it's
kind of like a venn diagram about 80 of
highly sensitive people are introverted
but then some are extroverts and then
not all introverts are sensitive so it's
complicated but he was definitely a
sensitive type
well there's on top of that you see like
the percent of artists related to the
average that suffer from depression so
creative people oh yeah it was very high
very very crazy yeah and then the number
of artists and successful artists who
were orphaned um when they were young
who lost one parent or both parents it's
like an astronomical number i have it in
the book i don't remember the percentage
but huge and he was one of them he lost
his father when he was nine
and his first act of poetry was
was he took his father made suits that's
why i thought of him when we were
talking about your suit
and um and he took one of his father's
bow ties and wrote a poem
in his honor and buried the poem and the
bow tie
in the backyard and that was like his
first creative act
you know that song um chelsea hotel
number two sure where he met i guess
it's about jenna's job joplin yeah
oh
what a fun
intense and cruel person she is
yeah
uh so i guess um have you ever seen uh
i'm sorry to interrupt you but have you
ever seen his son adam cohn and lana del
rey perform that song together oh wow no
it's incredible i have to send it to you
yeah so that for people who don't know i
don't i mean maybe i don't know
it goes i remember you well in the
chelsea hotel you're talking so brave
and so sweet
giving me head
on the unmade bed
while the limousines wait in the street
there's a good line in there about um
about being ugly oh yeah we are ugly but
we have the music no before that from a
guy's perspective it was uh oh you told
me again you preferred handsome men but
for me you would make an exception yeah
so good
well she continued that thread in in
later because i think she said that he
was lousy in bed
oh is that right yeah she publicly said
that which is like ah man
[Laughter]
just
okay for people who don't know i think
this is a true story about them
interacting and
and
being together for a very brief time i
don't know dating but just connecting
falling in love or
in in this only in this very particular
way that i think
famous musicians poets can can which is
like it's impossible for that kind of
thing to last
uh but they they did for a brief um
moment there's like a sadness to it
because it's so momentarily
but it's so epic
yeah that these two pass across and you
just look at we know these famous people
and it's it's it's interesting to watch
yeah and you don't even have the
impression that they're thinking it's
gonna last they more know that it's like
a blaze of an intersection yeah and the
you know the limousine's already waiting
while they're in the moment in the
middle of it and then it's done um
yeah
but he talked about how his music
he said he said something like some
people are more inclined to say hello
with their music but i'm rather more
valedictory that's what he said what is
valid like saying goodbye like the
valedictorian's address
interesting
you know so many of his songs really are
about some form of parting or goodbye or
an imperfection or something or like the
broken hallelujah
um
but the thing that's so
incredible about him
is the
is the way that he's taking all of that
and pointing it in the direction of
transcendence
like it's not
it's not just pure sadness it's sadness
and beauty and that's the thing
yeah there is a feeling of transcendence
in a lot of the songs
it's like sadness and transcendence
you're right it's a goodbye
but you're moving on to some
bigger thing
uh but in a sort of ethereal way like
not like a proud
arrogant way yeah
so his favorite poet was uh garcia lorca
he actually named his daughter after him
his daughter's name is lorca and um
and he talks about how
there's some poem that lorca had written
that made him realize that
the universe itself was aching but the
ache was okay because that's the way you
embrace the sun and the moon
and that's what i think is
that's why i think there's this whole um
rich vein in
in this
bittersweet tradition that he embodies
that's like the essence of beauty you
know it's the way you embrace the sun
and the moon the song hallelujah i
returned to that often
have been meaning to play it
um
i have now a friend who wants to sing it
with me
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
when somebody says they're a singer do
they have to be good
because then no
but i would say yes i was in a band for
a while i sang for a while i was always
bad but i
um i enjoy it i enjoy it i enjoy lyrics
i enjoy words yeah when sung or spoken
they capture something like again that
moment
uh tom waits is a huge favor of mine for
that reason
um although he often his lyrics are
often
not that
not that simple
i i'd rather have a bottle in front of
me than a pharma lobotomy he's always
playing with just like
these weird
word play that's
especially in the english language is
trickier to do i'm fortunate enough to
know another language which is russian
so i get to understand that certain
languages allow for more world war play
than others
english for that reason i don't think
has a
um like
like a like a culture of you know what i
need to push back on what i'm about to
say but there was no
culture of
word play
until hip-hop came along
so like
like distorting words in interesting
ways for there to be a rhythm a rhyme
and at the same time you're capturing
some really powerful message
um
plus humor
all of that mixed in actually hip-hop
does it does a really good job with this
but there wasn't a tradition if you look
at poetry in the 20th century there
wasn't really a tradition of that in the
united states but there was
in other parts of the world and
certainly in russia
interesting empowered also not just by
the language by the fact that you go
through a world war where tens of
millions of people die something about
mass
mass death of civilians that inspires
great literature and music and art
yeah absolutely because you start
telling the real truth i think yes
there's no more reason for small talk
that's funny i always
have thought that
if i could choose any other medium
besides writing it would be singing
um
but then you're a singer no i mean like
i'm really not i just love the idea of
it but then i also think you know i'm
fundamentally a shy person so i think
it's much better that my medium is
writing instead of singing so like it
all worked out
you